this week on brian ross investigates the
cloud over the olympics
you just can't have successful olympic
games when the host is committing
atrocity price it's not possible
a focus on the treatment of the minority
group the uyghurs the mass detentions
torture and force separations the
chinese don't want athletes or
journalists talking about you can assume
that your communications will be
monitored that spyware may be put in
that your room will be bugged
plus the mayor of san jose california
with the new law aimed at doing
something about america's gun violence
the first of its kind requiring gun
owners to take out liability insurance
the city passed a first of its kind
nation gun law gun owners will have to
pay an annual fee and keep liability
insurance and this week's winners and
losers in the media see if you agree
with the choices made by the editors of
mediaite
the holocaust isn't about race
from the studios of the law and crime
trial network in new york city's herald
square this
is brian ross investigates
and good evening and thank you for
joining us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live i'm brian ross joined as
always by my colleague rhonda schwartz
and rhonda we begin tonight with the
dark cloud over the winter olympics
underway this week in china as human
rights groups decry the country's
miserable human rights record and
journalists there find themselves unable
to freely report what's going on rhonda
that's right brian and the focus is on
the chinese how the chinese government
has been treating a large ethnic
minority group the uyghurs something
chinese officials are hoping will get
drowned out with all the pageantry and
puffery that comes with the olympics
the same government that is hosting
those olympics is also continuing to
commit crimes against humanity targeting
uyghurs this includes mass arbitrary
detention
torture
forced separations of families including
very young children separated from their
parents
cultural persecution
enforced disappearances primarily
located in the northwest xinjiang
province more than 12 million uyghurs
live in china mostly muslims they have
long been seen by the chinese government
as disloyal and as dangerous inside
china's controversial internment camps
more than a million uyghurs and others
belonging to various muslim minority
groups are believed to be detained in
the xinjiang region china calls them
thought transformation camps built to
prevent extremism from spreading but
reports indicate they're more like
prisons we've seen china's muslim
re-education camps the way the chinese
wanted us to see them on a tightly
controlled tour earlier this year
and we've seen glimpses from leaked
videos like this one
china says the camps stopped muslim
uighurs from becoming extremists and
offer free job training but now an
inside look in the chinese government's
own words a leaked nine-page memo reads
like a how-to manual telling officials
to strictly implement measures to
prevent escape that means 24 7 video
surveillance watch towers and double
lock doors and this is how thoughts are
transformed
long hours of rote learning chinese
[Applause]
the study of china's tightening
restrictions on religion
and the replacing of faith and cultural
identity
with a different loyalty
it's a different language distinct
religion culture
and the the authorities have perceived
this as evidence of separatism
human rights watch and other groups are
hoping the attention on the olympic
games will force action some of the good
steps would be certainly the
international olympic committee
fulfilling its obligations to defend in
human rights the same with the top
sponsors which includes a number of big
american companies like coke and intel
and visa
most important what we would like
to see is a global audience understand
that behind all of
the pomp and the pageantry and what will
undoubtedly be extraordinary athletic
performances
you know is a government that is highly
repressive
and committing
gross systemic violations
that if committed by pretty much any
other government in the world would
already be well under investigation with
a view towards prosecutions
american athletes will be in china in
large numbers but citing the human
rights issues the united states is
carrying out a kind of diplomatic
boycott no senior u.s official will be
present for the games the biden
administration will not send any
diplomatic or official representation to
the beijing 2022 winter olympics and
paralympic games given the pierre scenes
ongoing genocide and crimes against
humanity and xinjiang and other human
rights abuses the athletes on team usa
have our full support
we will be behind them 100 percent as we
cheer them on from home we will not be
contributing to the fanfare of the games
us diplomatic or official representation
would treat these games as business as
usual in the face of the prc's egregious
human rights abuses and atrocities in
xinjiang and we simply can't do that the
goal here really is not to punish the
athletes they don't have a say
in where they compete but i think we
need to look very carefully at the
complete moral bankruptcy of the ioc and
its unwillingness to uphold even its own
human rights standards with respect to
host cities you know the chinese
government refused to fulfill the human
rights commitments it made to get the
2008 olympics
so the fact that the ioc gave it another
round of the games without seeking
improvements
is pretty problematic but china has
taken steps to prevent any public
criticism from athletes or journalists
just last week a very senior member of
the chinese olympic organizing committee
made very clear that athletes and
support staff and coaches
who spoke in his words in contravention
of chinese laws and regulations which
are incredibly vague on free speech and
in violation of the olympic spirit also
very vague would face certain punishment
and those are his words certain
punishment
and that has sent a real chill you just
can't have successful olympic games when
the host is committing atrocity crimes
it's not possible
we're joined now by john powers veteran
boston globe sports reporter who has
covered every olympic for the last 22
years but john you're not going to china
this year why not uh we wanted to go we
went to tokyo last summer in spite of
covet but the barriers this time in a
number of ways
just argued against it uh barriers to
getting into the country
uh what we would be able to do while
we're there the closed loop
quote-unquote where you're not allowed
to be out in the city
uh concerns about um government
surveillance
uh all of it added up to um
we probably was better off or no worse
off covering the games from here
and you're not the only uh reporter or
journalist not to be going nbc for
instance is doing his broadcast uh their
announcers are going to be in
connecticut
yep and i think espn is doing the same
and john is it fair to say that as a
journalist you felt you really couldn't
do your job the way you'd like to
because of restrictions you couldn't be
out in the streets in china
no as a matter of fact you were going to
be followed
uh and because we have iphones that they
that they know about
they could trace you
we're also told many of the people who
are going
have been told bring disposable iphones
and disposable laptops because you can
assume that your communications will be
monitored that spyware may be put in
that your room will be bugged uh so we
talked to lawyers and other experts and
they said you can assume that actually
that's the same advice that the us
olympic uh parallel paralympic committee
gave the athletes don't bring your own
stuff
do you think the chinese are concerned
you would look at issues involving their
human rights records i think so i know
that the athletes have certainly been
told
fairly recently that you can protest if
it's within the olympic spirit
as long as you don't criticize chinese
policy
so the human rights organizations have
warned american atheists especially
don't say anything over there
you know
so i think there is a chilling aspect to
this that we have not seen
at any other games ever
john powers i want to thank you so much
for being with us we'll read your
coverage in the boston globe and do the
best you can from a distance thanks so
much we are on to paris
we asked officials at the chinese
embassy in washington to appear on our
program tonight but we never heard back
up next we'll be joined by the mayor of
san jose california with a first of its
kind novel approach to this country's
out of control gun violence can it get
past the second amendment
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
we turn now to this country's continued
failure to find a solution to the
rampage of gun violence here but now
city officials in san jose california
think they have found a novel solution
that can pass muster with the second
amendment and could be used as a
template across the country requiring
gun owners to buy liability insurance as
a way to push for the safer handling of
their weapons
we begin with breaking news own a gun in
san jose and you will need insurance in
the past 30 minutes the city passed a
first of its kind nation gun law gun
owners will have to pay an annual fee
and keep liability insurance
so to learn more about this we're joined
now by the mayor of san jose
sam licardo mr mayor thank you so much
for joining us
how will this legislation work how it
will prevent gun violence
brian good to be with you uh there are
two components to this ordinance one
would require every gun owner to have
insurance just as any driver needs to
have insurance to drive in any state uh
the second
would require all gun owners in our city
to pay a small fee 25 annually that
would be paid to a non-profit foundation
which would invest those dollars
in gun violence prevention strategies
evidence-based approaches
ranging from suicide prevention and
mental health
to domestic violence reduction and
gun safety classes
we think by making these strategic
investments particularly targeting
those residents who live in homes in
which a gun is owned and that's the best
way to get at the tremendous risk
involved in gun ownership in this
country
mayor licardo last may there was a
terrible shooting in san jose nine
people killed plus a tenth the gunman
would this legislation in any way
prevent that from happening
well i can't pretend to know uh that we
could prevent a horrible tragedy
we know that no ordinance is going to
magically fall make a make a gun fall
out of the hands of a
of someone who's on a rampage who's
intent on causing mass harm like that uh
but we'd certainly like to have the
chance if we could roll back the tape a
year or two years to be able to have
mental health services provided to
somebody who owns a gun who's clearly
having issues as this gunman in
particular
had palpable evidence of
very serious mental health issues that
his co-workers and in fact even the u.s
customs service observed you know this
is something that we don't have
resources for like most cities we don't
actually run the health departments in
our counties we'd love to be able to
have resources to invest in those kinds
of interventions mayor ricardo a
question for you from rhonda schwartz
rhonda
gun rights groups have said this is
absolutely preposterous idea and they're
promising to sue you mayor what do you
make of their reaction and how are you
going to go up against that
well the reaction is more or less what
we anticipated
we've had a lawsuit already
we know that to file a lawsuit in this
country means exercising your seventh
amendment rights and you have to pay a
fee at the courthouse steps to file that
complaint
similarly for
a newspaper to publish a story about
this event
many of those newspapers pay taxes and
that has been upheld
by the supreme court and the mere fact
that it's a constitutional right doesn't
mean it can't be regulated or there
can't be a fee that attaches the
question is whether we're creating
barriers that are uh too burdensome in
the exercise of that right i'm confident
this is a very very modest uh fee and
and certainly not gonna impair anyone
from exercising the constitutional
rights in this country you know we we
certainly have a second amendment that
protects the right of every american to
own and possess a gun
but it doesn't require every taxpayer to
subsidize
the exercise of that right and right now
that's exactly what we're doing in
california we're spending 1.4 billion
dollars on the public cost of responding
to gun harm
mr mayor if you are successful here this
uphold is upheld by the courts this
could be a template for the rest of the
country
well we hope that other cities and
states will
in fact engage in this kind of
policy uh we want insurance companies to
get involved because we see how
effective that has been in reducing
deaths for example with regard to auto
accidents over five decades we've seen
eighty percent drop in auto related
fatalities because
people have been encouraged to buy cars
with analog brakes or airbags and we
have
good driver safety discounts uh you know
through
utilizing uh
risk adjusted premiums insurance
companies can encourage safer behavior
and we need that in a country with four
and a half million children that live in
a home where a gun is kept unlocked
and loaded and we know that gun safes
and trigger locks and gun safety classes
could go a long way to making those
homes much safer and preventing a lot
of harm
with so many guns in this country you're
up against a huge task in trying to get
gun safety laws passed
you're right
we have a country with more than 300
million guns and we're not going to
magically make
everyone safe with any ordinance or
statute what we're hoping is to make gun
ownership safer we're not going to take
guns away from anyone no one has to fear
a big bad government getting involved
here what we're trying to do is make
strategic investments with public money
that can resu reduce harm
uh and
encourage the private sector in the form
of insurance companies
to incentivize safer behavior all right
mayor sam ricardo san jose california
thank you so much for being with us here
this evening
it's great to be with you brian thank
you all right
we asked the national association of gun
rights to have someone appear here
tonight with the mayor but we did not
hear back from them well up next this
week's winners and losers two losers in
the media
two very big losers
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite and we're joined by
aidan mclaughlin who's the
editor-in-chief of media which like the
law and crime trial network is part of
the dan abrams media group and this week
aidan two losers and no winners the
first big loser jeff sucker at cnn out
abruptly resigning what's behind the
scenes
it's been that kind of weak brian um
jeff zucker uh was uh resigned today uh
he was actually pushed out of cnn a
network he has run since 2013. uh now
just to give you a little glimpse inside
cnn jeff sucker is beloved by almost
everyone who works at cnn and you saw a
series of
uh sort of fond notes pour out from
anchors and producers writers at cnn
were really sad to see this turn of
events
now what happened is uh jeff sucker
resigned this morning he announced his
resignation and he said that the reason
he was resigning is because he had a
relationship with allison gollist who is
an evp uh at cnn and is also the chief
marketing officer of the network
now they've had that relationship for uh
more than a year they said now since
they said it started in the pandemic but
they weren't together since uh they both
worked at nbc back in 2012 so the
relationship is has been going on for
quite a while now they said that the
reason that zucker was resigning is
because he did not disclose that he was
in this relationship with alan allison
golis which are supposed to do because
they're colleagues um now that was the
reason he said he was resigning i know
people at cnn uh have issues with that
allison camerota who's a host on the
network
she said she didn't understand why he
was resigning over a consensual
relationship just because he didn't
disclose it to hr um so i suspect
there's there's a little bit more to
this story we know that uh jason keelar
who is the head of warner media which is
cnn's current parent company has issues
his own issues with uh
jeff zucker and that jason killer was
the one who asked for jeff sucker's uh
resignation and said that he would be
terminated if jeff sucker didn't
announce it himself uh that's brian
stelter of cnn who reported that um so i
think i suspect in the coming days we'll
get a little bit more clarity on why
jeff sucker so abruptly resigned um but
it was clearly not his decision to do so
nate this seems to be more fallout from
the firing of chris cuomo by jeff zucker
that's right that's another sort of wild
element of this chris cuomo who was
fired by cnn in december uh because he
was advising his brother uh the former
new york governor on his sexual
harassment scandal um during the
investigation that cnn uh had uh
declared into that uh into that scandal
within its own network uh jeff zucker
was asked by the lawyers that cnn had
hired for that investigation uh whether
or not he was in this relationship with
allison gallis and that's when he
disclosed it and that's when jason
keelar asked for his resignation so it
all trails back to uh andrew cuomo's sex
scandal which is truly like a pretty
remarkable domino effect to have there
quite a blast radius as ben smith of the
new york times said finally let's go to
your second loser whoopi goldberg of
abc's the view who was suspended for two
weeks for these comments about the
holocaust
the holocaust isn't about race
no
no it's not about racism
it's about a different race but it's
it's not about race
it's not about race
because you it's about man's inhumanity
to man well she was widely criticized
for that uh went on the stephen colbert
show and apologized said the same thing
on the view but that wasn't enough for
abc which put her on a two-week
suspension
that's right uh so after those comments
there was a huge public backlash uh
whoopi goldberg issued a pretty lengthy
apology uh then uh the head of the
anti-defamation league appeared on the
view um to basically give the ladies the
view a lesson in uh the holocaust and uh
why it was indeed very much about race
um that still wasn't enough for abc uh
kim godwin who is the current uh
president of the network announced that
she uh the whoopi goldberg was being
suspended for two weeks uh so that she
could learn um i think it was sort of an
odd decision to suspend her for two
weeks is something the network sort of
has to answer for now um i i don't know
that there was that much of a public
demand for it usually in these
situations networks are caving to a big
public demand that they um sort of
punish a host for saying something
controversial in this case most people
at least that i saw in the pundit class
were a little bit baffled that would be
goldberg was being
suspended because there's not much to
investigate here um it's pretty much
tied up but you know i think this this
case is yet another one um in the uh and
what i think is an issue with the view
as a show which is that uh there are
people like whoopi goldberg who is an
actor um from hollywood who's commenting
on issues of great importance like the
holocaust that requires a deep
historical perspective to really get
right um it's sort of like joe rogan uh
you know talking about covid um and
vaccines without having any actual
expertise in it um so you know uh you
have these hosts on air all day um
talking live they're going to make
mistakes like this and i think this is a
good example of it all right indeed
we'll see what whoopi says about this
whether she takes it aiden thanks so
much for being with us tonight very much
appreciated thanks to all of you for
joining us that's our program for
tonight we'll see you back here again
next week
[Music]
you